Vas a una entrevista de trabajo
y lo primero que te dice la entrevistadora es
"Mira, tienes una gran experiencia de trabajo,
pareces ser una persona joven y agradable,
pero lo que realmente me interesa,
son tus habilidades de razonamiento lógico"
y lo que te dice es
"Mira solo siéntate te voy a preguntar algo
sobre algunas expresiones matemáticas",
y tú por supuesto dirás
"adelante hazme esas preguntas,
soy estudiante de la Khan Academy,
estoy seguro de mí mismo, échamelas."
Y entonces te dice
"¡Muy bien! Tú tienes 2 enteros "a" y "b" digamos,
1 entero "a", 1 entero "b"
donde "a" es mayor que 0, es positivo,
y "b" es menor que 0, es decir es negativo"
muy bien,
además te voy a dar otra relación.
Te dice que "a" entre "b" va a ser positiva...
va a ser más grande que "a" por "b"
muy bien,
entonces te dice la entrevistadora
"Dime algunas cosas interesantes de "a", de "b",
de "a" entre "b" y de "a" por "b"
¿Ok? Entonces tú dices, ok,
haré mi mejor esfuerzo
y aquí es el momento
en donde yo te recomiendo que hagas una pausa,
haz una pausa para que pienses
todas las relaciones posibles que puedas encontrar
de "a", "b", "a" entre "b", "a" por "b"
¿Ok?
Piensa en todas las restricciones
que se imponen
mutuamente con estas 3...
con estas 3 afirmaciones
¿Ok?.
Ok entonces, suponiendo que ya hiciste una pausa, vamos a continuar.
Digamos vamos a, vamos a tratar de analizar para quedar muy bien con nuestra
entrevistadora.
¿Cómo es "a" entre "b"?
"a" es un número positivo
y "b" es un número negativo
entonces, si tú divides "a" entre "b",
tienes algo positivo entre algo negativo,
este número de aquí es negativo,
muy bien,
¿qué pasa con "a" por "b"?.
Nuevamente este es un número positivo
y este uno negativo,
y un positivo por un negativo
nos da algo negativo,
entonces ya tenemos algo dicho ahí,
muy bien,
¿Cómo se vería todo esto en la recta numérica?
¿ok?
Digamos tenemos
aquí nuestra recta numérica...
digamos que por acá...
por aquí anda el 0
y entonces nuestra relación que tenemos aquí,
nos dice que "a" entre "b" es mayor que "a" por "b",
quiere decir que "a" por "b",
si ambos son negativos, al menos
"a" por "b" debe ser mucho más negativo,
entonces "a" entre "b"...
digamos si éste es "a" entre "b",
debe estar más cerca del 0
que lo que va a estar "a" por "b",
¿muy bien?
Entonces,
esto mismo nos está diciendo
que el valor absoluto de "a" entre "b"
debe ser mucho más chico que "a" por "b",
donde el valor absoluto
sabemos que es la distancia al 0
¿verdad?
De 0 a "a" entre "b",
hay una menor distancia
que de 0 a "a" por "b"
y entonces la entrevistadora
se ha quedado impresionada
y te dice
"Oye has dicho mucho,
de muy poquita información,
de sólo tres afirmaciones,
sin embargo yo quiero un poquito más
dame una restricción que deba tener "b"."
Entonces vamos a ponernos a pensar,
sabemos que al menos el valor absoluto,
de "a" entre  "b",
debe ser más chico
que el valor absoluto de "a" por "b",
sin embargo como que quizás de aquí
no sale mucho ésta...
quizás no es tan claro
cómo sacar la restricción sobre "b",
así que vamos a trabajar
sobre esta de aquí...
vamos a trabajar sobre esta de aquí
y multipliquemos por "b" de ambos lados,
entonces tengo a "a" entre "b"
y lo multiplicamos por "b"
y también del otro lado tengo "a" por "b"
y lo multiplicamos por "b",
sin embargo,
acabamos de multiplicar por "b"
y "b" es un número negativo,
así que cuando multiplicamos
por un número negativo
la desigualdad se invierte, se cambia,
entonces ahora tenemos un menor que.
Ok, vamos a continuar porque
"b" entre "b" se cancelan
y entonces me queda que "a"
es menor que "a" por "b" por "b"
y eso es "a" por "b" cuadrada
muy bien,
Ahora vamos a tratar de cancelar,
la "a",
dividiendo entre "a" de ambos lados,
sin embargo como "a" es positivo pues
aquí la desigualdad,
no hay nada más que hacerle.
Así que "a" entre "a" se vuelve 1,
"a" entre "a" se cancela
y nos queda que 1 es menor que "b"cuadrada,
o lo que es lo mismo
que el valor absoluto de "b"
es mayor que 1,
y tú dirás
"Oye, a ver ¿De dónde salió esto?".
An bueno, pues es claro
que si "b" es más grande que 1
el cuadrado seguirá siendo más grande que 1,
por ejemplo
2 al cuadrado es 4,
3 al cuadrado es 9
y así sucesivamente,
¿verdad?
Sin embargo también debe cumplir,
bueno aquí tenemos que "b",
mayor que 1,
o bien,
también sabemos que "b"
puede ser menor que -1
y es exactamente el mismo argumento
¿verdad?
Si "b" es más chico que -1,
"b" cuadrada va a ser más grande que 1
por ejemplo,
si "b" es -2 pues el cuadrado
es -2 por -2 que es 4 positivo ,
muy bien,
entonces estas 2 afirmaciones son equivalentes a
que "b" cuadrada sea mayor que 1
pero también esto
es equivalente a esto,
muy bien,
entonces tenemos justamente,
ya la restricción de "b"
y entonces
hay que pensar todavía
un último detalle,
porque no estamos considerando que "b" es negativo,
entonces si "b" es negativo
pues esta opción queda descartada,
y por lo tanto,
lo único que sabemos es
ahora,
que "b" es más chico que -1
y entonces,
después de todo este análisis,
tu entrevistadora estará muy impresionada
y seguramente dirá
"Mira,
¡Haz hecho un gran razonamiento aquí!
Creo que mereces el empleo."